hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast laboratory diagnosis of
von willebrand disease presented by dr.
Larry Smith manager medical and
scientific affairs hematology advic
Diagnostics I'm Alexis Corrales and I
will be your moderator for this
educational web seminar presented by
lappers and sponsored by Abbott
Diagnostics before we begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation is click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window to
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble cream or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
I'd like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. Larry Smith dr. Larry Smith
received his doctorate in biological
sciences from Fordham University Bronx
New York and completed his certificate
in molecular laboratory Diagnostics at
Michigan State University he completed
his postdoctoral studies in gene therapy
and experimental hematopoiesis Guzzi at
Columbia University College of
Physicians and Surgeons New York and was
a research fellow in immunology at
Fordham University in addition dr. Smith
has a Master of Science and medical
biology and ambassador of science in
French and biology he holds multiple
board certificates and has published
numerous peer-reviewed articles abstract
reviews and monographs his research
interests include laboratory test
development for hemostasis and
coagulation HPC therapy
applications and flow cytometry for a
complete biopsy I'm dr. Smith please
click his photo in the top left corner
of your screen welcome dr. Smith you may
now begin your presentation please join
me in welcoming dr. Larry Smith I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Alexis thank you very much for that
introduction and I'd like to thank all
of the of the audience for your for
attending today's lecture this is on
laboratory diagnosis of fun Willebrand
disease this these are my disclosures
actually I had nothing to disclose I do
lecture for a ESCP and I'm currently an
adjunct professor at Rutgers University
in New Jersey now prior to joining avid
I was director of the coagulation
laboratory assistant director of human
ecology and flow cytometry at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center what I'd
like to do over the next 45 minutes is
to define to define von Willebrand
disease and tell you a little bit about
it about its history we'll review the
current classification of animal brain
disease and discuss some of the acids
that are utilized in the diagnosis of
this disorder we will review the
structure and function of the protein
and then we'll look at some of the
methods that are very essential in the
diagnosis of uh global brain disease
we'll look at some of the limitations of
those methods will look at some pre
analytical variables that influence
their testing in the laboratory as well
as how we interpret the results from
those essays so to start with but will
approach disease is a disorder of
primary hemostasis we know that we have
disorders of primary hemostasis that
involves blood vessels in platelets and
we have disorders of secondary in the
stasis that involve the coagulation
factors so here we're just going to
focus on those disorders in the primary
hemostasis realm but we'll bring disease
in the most common congenital bleeding
abnormality in the world in terms of
frequency affects about one
percent of the general population but
not everyone who has von Willebrand
disease will actually bleed let their
charity it's only symptomatic in about
one in 10,000 individuals in terms of
its history it was described by dr.
earth von Willebrand who was an
internist working in Finland and he was
taking care of a five-year-old girl from
the åland Islands who presented with a
bleeding disorder now this bleeding
disorder appeared to have somewhat of an
autosomal dominant pattern of
inheritance she presented with
mucocutaneous bleeding a prolonged
bleeding time and a family history of
bleeding now unfortunately she died in
her early teens from increased menstrual
bleeding dr. von Willebrand howard
however did recognize that this bleeding
pattern that this little girl presented
with was a little different from the
classic mo philia that that they had
diagnosed in the past and usually boys
presented with this type of bleeding
disorder and so with that he decided
that she had what appeared to be an
autosomal mode of inheritance and he
actually wrote a paper about it in 1926
and he wasn't really sure what to call
it so he called it pseudo hemophilia now
as a disorder of priority list aces some
of the clinical manifestations will
include mucocutaneous bleeding that's a
variant severity in both males and
females some of these some of these
characteristics will be ecchymosis
epistaxis gastrointestinal bleeding
general bleeding and menagerie females
the basic pattern physiology that we see
in bond will break disease is due to a
defective platelet adhesion and the
concurrent reduced level up factor 8
this slide shows you of the actual
structure of the Bund Willebrand factor
gene that's responsible for this protein
the protein itself is a large
multi-layered protein and it ranges in
size from 600 Dalton's all the way up to
greater than 20 million Dalton so it's a
really large protein that's produced
it's produced on the short arm of
chromosome 12 and it consists of about
178 kilo bases with 52 exons
now if you look at the middle of the
screen we can actually see the structure
of the gene that's responsible for bun
Willebrand disease and and that that
again is it's synthesized on chromosome
number of number 12 the short arm
there's also another gene that can give
rise to a little bread factor and this
is a pseudo gene that's located on
chromosome 22 the next diagram of the
very middle of the screen represents the
complementary DNA the DNA was clawed the
gene was actually cloned in the late 80s
or so and this represents the structure
of that complementary DNA as you can see
here it consists of two regions a
polypeptide region and immature subunit
these sections are made up of various
domains D 1 D 2 D prime D 3 etc and this
is a very heterogeneous disorder so
mutations can occur along any of these
particular domains we can also see where
the von Willebrand factor interacts with
factor 8 that somewhere here with is a
deep prime and part of the deeper domain
we can see where it interacts with the
glycoprotein 1b receptor of the
platelets in this particular region and
also with the glycoprotein to b3
receptors of platelets in this
particular region here in addition but
Willebrand factor interacts with
collagen in two different regions that
we can see at the very bottom of the
slide and now understanding where these
mutations occurred is very central
because it results in different
phenotypic expressions of them
diseased imitation that occurs here in
the deep prime region what would result
in a presentation that would call type
to end von Willebrand disease where
there is an abnormal interaction with
the factor a molecule the mutation that
occurred in this a - domain would result
in something that we call - a fun
Willebrand disease so these really help
us in terms of actually diagnosing these
patients when we understand where these
mutations occur in terms of the
synthesis of the von Willebrand factor
of von willebrand factor synthesized in
two different regions it synthesizes in
endothelial cells we know that
endothelial cells make up or surround
the actual blood vessels in our bodies
and it's also synthesized in
megakaryocytes now once it's synthesized
it's actually stored in an organelle
within the endothelial cells called the
libel Pilate bodies in megakaryocytes
employment it's stored in the alpha
granules now as the protein is
synthesized it starts out as a monomer
or single-chain this is called the pre
pro bun Willebrand factor monomer and as
it begins to move to the endoplasmic
reticulum that is moved out of the
nucleus into the endoplasmic reticulum
the signal peptide region is cleaved off
and then this monomer actually undergoes
the dimerization so we go from one chain
to two chains these two chains are then
compiled Inc together at their carboxy
terminal in and then as the protein then
leaves the endoplasmic reticulum and
moves on to the Golgi apparatus it
undergoes a multimers ation so that just
simply means that we go from two chains
or a dimer into four chains eight 16 32
64 etcetera until we end up with this
really large a module now once it's
fully
the size the pro-peptide region gets
cleaved off and then this large
structure it gets becomes very tightly
coiled and then it's stored in the wild
Pilate body now in terms of the release
of a little brain factor there are a
number of theories how it actually gets
out of the wild Pilate body into the
circulation and so it really doesn't
matter which one of the theories you
believe but if you look at this the area
where I'm pointing to that section D on
the slide here there is wondering that
the Y will pull on body move up to the
region where the damaged endothelial has
occurred and then the Y button Pilate
body releases these very long strands of
bun Willebrand factor now these very
longest strands are these unusually
large of multimers above all brent
factor can actually be very dangerous
because they're very a key sector
platelets so in order to prevent
platelet agglutination from occurring
within our blood vessels located on top
of the endothelial cell and this is the
figure on the right side of this the
right side of this line is a protein
that's called adam gs-13 it's also
called the von Willebrand factor
Cleveland protease and as it appears on
this slide it looks like a pair of
scissors in a sense and so as these
unusually large multimers of von
willebrand factor are released the pair
of scissors or the idea of thirteen sits
there and cleaves these this protein
into much smaller fragments and so the
smaller fragments available of Greg
Packard and are not as adhesive to those
platelets and so then we have the normal
BUN Willebrand factor in our circulation
now in terms of the function of von
willebrand factor there are actually
only two functions that have been
assigned to the Liljegren factor the
first one is that it's served as a line
in that binds to the glycoprotein 1b
receptor of platelets once it binds to
those platelets it will then pull the
platelet down to the damaged endothelial
layer so it actually
we'll actually vice to the glycoprotein
1b receptor as well as to the collagen
that now exposed in the damaged skin to
Belial layer this particular function
leads to what's called platelet adhesion
or we form a monolayer of platelets on
the damaged interview with a surface the
second function of one Willebrand factor
is that it serves as a carrier proteins
or factories so it's in other words in
protects Factory in the circulation
Factory
once it's produced will come out into
the circulation and but Willebrand
factor will basically wrap around it to
protect it from our from unnecessary
cleavage or proteolysis and then it also
called localizes it's factory to the
site of injury so that factory can then
function in the coagulation of cascade
now moving on to some of the assays that
we use to classify bun Willebrand
disease i've actually divided these
assays into three groups of these are
all screening assays factor 8 see when a
little grant factor antigen and bun
Willebrand factor activity these are all
necessary axes for the most basic
diagnosis of on will attract disease and
I'm sure all of your laboratories do all
of these all three of these assays in
the box in the middle I have some
additional assays that can be used in
the diagnosis of unwilling brain disease
so they are just an adjunct to what to
the first 3 assays this would include
the bleeding time and/or a platelet
function screen or PFA 100 PMA 200 I
would imagine that most of us no longer
do an actual bleeding time and so we've
all switched to the PFA 100/200 to
perform or to replace the bleeding time
and in the third boxes on the right
there are two other athletes that are
listed here
multiple timer analysis this is somewhat
a little more complicated than the other
two boxes and certainly platelet
aggregation
these also in further classifying the
type of von willebrand disease that
we're talking about understanding these
assays then and performing these axes
will then allow us to classify
Buttonwillow Bret disease so we
contrabass von Willebrand disease into
two broad categories we have the
disorders that appear to be a
quantitative defect so a quantitative
defect would be a decrease in the amount
of protein that's present but the
protein is is normal in terms of its
function now under this category we have
something called type 1 bundle of Brett
disease and this is a partial
quantitative deficiency of the disorder
and then we have type 3 von Willebrand
disease this is a complete absence for
very severely decreased amount of the
bundle branch factor protein the second
broad category would be those disorders
that are due to a qualitative defect so
here we have a defective
protein or dis protein emia now we may
have a normal amount of the protein or
it may be decrease somewhat but the
point the main point is the protein
itself is defective now these are
divided into four subgroups we have type
2 8 x 2b type 2 m and type 2 n so let's
look a little further into these actual
actual categories of unloaded disease so
we'll first look at the quantitative
defect so again here we have a normal
protein in terms of its function but we
have a decreased amount of that protein
so the first disorder that we'll look at
is called type 1 but will write disease
this is the most common presentation of
for patients with hland will read these
it about 80% of patients who do present
with the disorder will fall into this
category it's characterized by a
homothug sorry by a heterozygous
mutation
that leads to this partial quantitative
deficiency so if you can imagine we have
two alleles that are present and one of
the if one of the alleles is each one of
these alleles will produce let's say
about 50% of the bundle a brand factor
that we have so if one of those alleles
is mutated or one of those alleles is
acid then the remaining normal allele
will produce it's 50% of von willebrand
factor so as a result we have a reduced
amount since von Willebrand factor
protects factories in the circulation
we'll also have a concomitant decrease
in the amount of factories because we
just don't make enough of the von
Willebrand factor to protect it in this
circulation now in terms of how these
patients present in the clinical and
with type 1 but a little brain disease
they're bleeding symptoms can range from
a symptomatic in other words we don't
see any bleeding at all unless they're
really challenged up to just a very mild
bleeding diathesis so a very wide range
in terms of bleeding symptoms when they
present to the clinic now understanding
that this is type 1 when will brain
disease is also very advantageous
because it's very easy to treat these
individuals since the protein that's
produced is a normal protein but just
not enough of the protein we can simply
give these individuals a drug called
ddavp dear me know 8d arginine base are
present they so present which is just
simply we can give it in the form of a
nasal spray they spray it into their
nose and this then will cause the
endothelial cells to release more of the
vanilla bran factor from those
endothelial cells into the circulation
it's okay because this is a normal one
will drag factor protein in terms of its
function so a real easy solution for
treating patients with type 1 when
Willebrand disease what would we see in
the laboratory in a patient
presents with type-1 by the little rat
disease well again we only have a slight
reduction so we could expect to see
normal to a decreased level of factor
eight a normal to decrease level of von
willebrand factor activity or if you
call that there is de seton cofactor
assays that would be normal to decrease
and we'd also see a normal to decrease
the amount of the actual protein that's
measured by the von Willebrand factor
antigen assay now I say normal because
it all depends on what your lure limit
is on your reference range if your lower
limit is 50% and you have one allele
that's producing but it Willebrand
factor then there's your 50% if it's if
that one allele produces 40% or 35% then
that's what you would have and did that
level might be considered decrease but
the range is normal to decrease for
these three tests if you were to do a
bleeding time usually in type one with a
little Brett disease other bleeding time
is prolonged and so that would relate
that would translate into a PFA 100 also
having a prolonged closure time and then
finally if you were to do multiple
analysis if you look at the the cartoon
on the right side of the screen when you
do multiple analysis and I'll explain it
in a little more detail on a later slide
but we're simply looking at the we're
simply electrical work placing a sample
on a gel apply the circuit and we're
separating the multimers of unwilling
bread effector at least on their size
and so what you can see here in this in
this diagram is in lane one that says
normal with the blue dots around it we
can see that we have three sizes of
these von Willebrand factor Moulton
where I'm circling at the top would be
the large molecular weight multimers and
then we have the intermediate molecular
weight multimers just below and in below
that the really large motors
the bottom would be the
low-molecular-weight multimers so high
molecular weight intermediate molecular
weight and low molecular weight
multiples all three sizes of these
monomers are present when we look at
someone with type 1 funny little brain
disease where we see the red box in lane
2 we see that we still have all three
sizes of these multimers present the
high molecular weight multimers the
intermediate and the low molecular
weight multimers but note in terms of
the intensity of the staining of each of
these individual bands it's a lot less
so therefore in type 1 one will cry to
these if you were to do multimeric
analysis what you would find is that all
three sizes of the multimers are present
but you just don't have as much of the
protein when you compare it to someone
that's normal okay now moving on to type
3 von Willebrand disease this is the
most severe form of a little Ren disease
and unfortunately it only affects about
one to five percent of the general
population and is usually seen in cases
where there is an increase in consent
winners marriages so that's where it's
more prevalent now this results from a
homozygous mutation that leads to a
complete deficiency of one little grant
factor so now if you can imagine two
alleles and it remember to eat your
little for just about 50% of whatever
amount of unwilling brain factor that
you have is one of the alleles is
missing or both are missing or if one is
missing and one is defective or if both
of the alleles the alleles are defective
you can see then that you would not be
able to really produce any bun
Willebrand factor when these papers we
measure the bun will the blood will
attract factor levels in these patients
it certainly ranges from 0 up to
somewhere in less than 5%
now since factoring is protected by von
Willebrand factor in the circulation and
now we don't have anybody Willebrand
factor then you would expect to see a
much
or decrease in the level of circulate in
factories and usually these levels are
low but they're not as low as what we
might see in someone with severe
hemophilia since von Willebrand factor
then also a plays a role in platelet
function and we don't if we did not have
any of this one Willebrand factor you
would expect that these patients might
present with some spontaneous bleeding
certainly severe mucocutaneous bleeding
since this is one of the characteristics
of primary hemostasis and then these
patients also can bleed into the soft
tissues as well as into the muscles and
into the joints so and this particular
bleeding pattern might be consistent
with hemophilia but again this would not
be familiar since its type three run
Willebrand disease now turning to the
qualitative defects these are a little
more complicated than than the
quantitative effects so here we have an
abnormal protein that's present so it's
there's something that's intrinsically
wrong with the protein itself that it
doesn't function properly
however the levels of this protein may
be normal to decrease very often their
normal levels so in the first disorder
that we'll look at is called time to
eight von Willebrand disease now kind of
too late my little brain disease a
result from a mutation that occurred in
the 8th - domain you remember when I
showed you the cDNA and we saw all of
the domains so this mutation would occur
in this specific region and this is a
region where bun will well where the one
Willebrand factor interacts with
platelets as well as with collagen so
here we have a loss of the platelet
dependent function if we were to look at
multimers in these patients what we
would see is that when we look for the
high molecular weight multiverse they
are missing when we look for the
intermediate molecular multimers they're
missing and we only see the low
molecular weight multimers in the
scenario now there are several theories
- what happens to this one will break
back origines multimers and one of the
theories is that there is an abnormal
assembly and secretion of the protein
and the second theory is that once this
protein is produced there is an increase
accessibility of this protein to
proteolytic cleavage once it gets into
the circulation now since we have lost
those higher molecular weight multimers
which have this platelet adhesive
quality you would expect to see an
increase or somewhere from a moderate to
severe mucocutaneous bleeding in these
patients
the next disorder would be type 2 in
Wilburn disease now here the mutation
occur in the 81 domain of the bun
Willebrand factor now this is a very
tricky mutation because it results in a
loss of only the high molecular weight
multimers remember in type 2 we lost the
high and the intermediate but in time -
in fact - eight
but in time to me we only loses a high
level early multimers now this mutation
that occurs is called a gain of function
mutation now so that means that the
mutation that's occurring in the bun
Willebrand factor it's such that it has
an increased affinity to bind to the
glycoprotein 1b receptor of the
platelets that are just simply sort of
floating by or circulating in the blood
so the von Willebrand factor jumps to
grab on to the platelet this results in
spontaneous binding of these flavours
are taken out of the circulation
resulting in thrombocytopenia and in
addition there is this rapid loss of
those large von Willebrand factor
multiples now as you can see this
particular type of von willebrand factor
is really abnormal so in terms of
treating these patients with type 2
level brain disease we would definitely
not want to give them ddavp
because we don't want to put more of
that gun bullet right factor into the
circulation so GDP would be
contraindicated
to von Willebrand disease the next guy
in
it's called type 2 m1 will read disease
and here there's a mutation in the a1
binding domain and this simply leads to
a decrease in platelet function now I
tried to schematically draw what this
would look like and as you can see it on
the diagram on the right the mutation
occurs and prevents the glycoprotein 1b
from binding to the bud Willebrand
factor but note that where factor 80
where von Willebrand factor binds to
factory there is no abnormality there so
if we were to test for the level of
factor 8 in these patients if we were to
test for factoring in these patients the
factory would be normal if we test do
multimeric analysis we would have high
intermediate and low molecular weight
multimers present in these patients in
these in this particular category so we
just simply have a defect in the
platelet dependent function in the
scenario the next type is called type to
end von Willebrand disease this is also
referred to as thought of soul in philia
or the Normandy variant I was actually
described in Normandy in in France
now this of the mutation here is where
but will break factor binds to factor 8
if you look to the right side of the
cartoon there you see I put a little
arrow of your ensure that factory cannot
bind this one will drag factor but note
that in in terms of platelets binding to
the bun Willebrand factor there is
absolutely no problem there so there's
normal platelet adhesion but the bun
Willebrand factor simply cannot protect
factories in the circulation so now if
we go back to the laboratory and test
patients with type 2 in my little brain
disease as we would suspect we'd have a
decrease in the level of factor 8 and
this would be similar to like a mild
single philia if we measure the amount
of oil
dr. antigen and the von Willebrand
factor activity these would be normal
because we have a normal amount of
protein but it's just a this protein
emia that we're looking at and if we do
a bleeding time or have a 100 in
patients with type 2 and bundle brain
disease we actually get a normal result
so this would be once in one of the only
categories of my little pregnancies
where the bleeding time is really normal
and that's because there is no problem
with a platelet adhesion in these
patients
now the next of disorder that we'll talk
about very quickly it's called pseudo
von Willebrand disease or platelet type
and Willebrand disease and this is not
really a defect in von Willebrand factor
itself but rather a defect within the
platelets so here when a little Brent
factor is normal now the defect or the
mutation occurs in the platelet
glycoprotein 1b receptor that results in
a gain of function mutation so if you
remember the gain of function mutation
that we talked about type 2 b1 will read
to these well this same type of mutation
occurs here in the platelets but this
time the platelets have an increased
binding affinity for the von Willebrand
factor so the blood will the what the
bund Willebrand factor is normal and the
printless jump to grab on to the von
Willebrand factor so the presentation is
is is is identical to what we see with
type 2 b1 will write disease but in this
case this is not the little brains needs
in terms of the laboratory findings
they're all the same
since the platelets are going to bind to
the von Willebrand factor it's we're
going to lose the high molecular weight
multimers when we look at multiple
multiple analysis we're going to have
thrombocytopenia because we're filling
the platelets out of the circulation and
a test that i have not mentioned but i
will talk about it a little later is a
platelet aggregation using low-dose mr.
Seaton this particular assay it really
does help to identify patients with
pseudo von Willebrand disease as well as
type 2b von Willebrand disease so here's
the case where platelet aggregation
using various doses of reseeding but in
particularly low doses mr. Seaton would
help us to differentiate these two
presentations of von willebrand disease
from all of the others
now since the defect here is in the
platelets we would not want to give
these patients the same treatment than
with different patients with Truman
Willebrand disease because we just
simply be adding fuel to somewhat of a
fire if we did so now at the beginning
of the talk we said the blood Willebrand
disease was the most common congenital
bleeding abnormality in the world but
there is an entity that's called a
carbon Willebrand disease so any of you
that are listening to this can actually
acquire an Willebrand disease and it
results in a qualitative structural
functional defect within the von
Willebrand factor molecule and it leads
to an increased risk for bleeding
there are several mechanisms to explain
how this can occur and the first one is
due to an autoimmune clearance an
antibody that that forms that inhibits
the von Willebrand factor and leads to
an increase clearance of the von
Willebrand factor from the circulation
and some of the disorders where this is
seen would be some of the
lymphoproliferative disorders such as
chronic lymphocytic leukemia in GUP the
monoclonal gammopathy of unknown a
specificity and certainly patients with
systemic lupus erythematosus another
mechanism that can lead your partner
will release is a low functioning
thyroid gland so hypothyroidism now this
in a non immunity mediated mechanism but
the result would be the same often when
patients have a aortic valve youlet
stenosis or they have a left ventricular
assist device these result sometimes in
a fluid shear stress induced proteolysis
whereby the valves are kind of hard and
they clamp down on the bundle of are in
fact
causing it to be uncoiled leading to it
its cleavage so this would deplete some
of the larger molecular weight multimers
of a little brain factor to other
mechanisms that are associated with
required but a little bread back there
would be an increased binding of von
willebrand factor to the services of
platelets so in in one of the
myeloproliferative neoplasms essential
thrombocythemia we have platelet counts
that can get up to over a million and
just having that surface there can
attract can draw some of the von
Willebrand factor out of the circulation
and then finally there are a number of
drugs that have been associated with an
acquiring on Willebrand disease now one
of the things that you look for in the
laboratory certainly is a the ratio of
the activity to the antigen does not
always match so we have this discrepancy
and so this is really very very
characteristic we've seen in many cases
of requires and we'll dragazines
now turning to look at some of those
annotations that we've already talked
about but to look a little more in depth
at the assays again we have the
screening assays the bleeding hammer
play the function screen followed by the
sensual screening assay in structure 8
but Willebrand factor and E&S AIDS among
will read activity I say now this
activity as they can be divided into a
number of different assays depending on
what your laboratory uses and then we
have more conformational assays such as
multiple analysis and receiving whose
plated aggregation and there are others
but we're living in for time so I just
listed some of some of the more common
assays so get very quickly concerning
the the PSA 100 or caffeine 200 if you
look at the diagram on the left this
represents an injured blood vessel we
know that all blood vessels in the body
are surrounded by a single layer of
endothelial cells and when we dam extend
endothelial layer we expose a layer of
subinterval
collagen microfibrils and we also
damaged that rival colada body that
stores the von Willebrand factor as a
result of an Willebrand factor leaves
the Bible Pilate body ink comes into the
little bit of the blood vessel it
attaches to the southern ethereal
collagen layer and then it goes up and
looks for those platelets platelets
buying via that glycoprotein wonder your
scepter and the medulla Brett Becker's
pulled down onto the damaged endothelial
surface it forms this mono layer and
this is the initial protection that
occurs and we know that later platelets
will aggregate and then our coagulation
proteins will then come together and
form a stable clock here well the same
thing that happens in the PFA 100
whereby we have a column we introduce
blood into the column and then there's a
little pressure that pushes the blood up
through the column and as these
platelets then interact with collagen
that's located in the cartridge or with
one of the platelet agonists we know
that the platelets will appear and then
as a result of the collagen and the
flavors will then aggregate as a result
of either epinephrine or ATP that's been
added to the cartridge and then at some
point the plug it gets to be so large
that the analyzer can no longer push the
blood up through the cartridge and egg
results in a closure time so it's very
very similar to what happens in vivo
this would be the in vitro and
disobedient people phenomenon how good
is the PSA 100 in in diagnosing patients
with blood a little break disease well
if you look at all types of uncool brain
disease with the exception to n we have
type 1 280 to reach 11 times three other
PRA 100 has a sensitivity of about 85 to
90% now if we only look at the type 2
and type 2 a type to be tagged to 11
times 3
then the sensitivity can go up to
somewhere around 98% based on a number
of studies that have been
been done looking at a little bright
factor at the CFA 100 the PSAT 100 by
itself certainly cannot say that a
person has been will brain disease but
it will have a consistent activity in
the presence of individuals with one
Willebrand disease turning to some of
the other acids the first actually would
be up the antigen assay this actually
simply measures the amount of protein
that's present it's an immunoassay and
it generally involves up most of these
are latex immunoassay so they involve
latex beads that are coated with an
antibody this antibody is specific
formula grant tracker and so when we add
a patient's plasma that contains von
Willebrand factor it will bind to these
antibodies and these beads will then
ultimately fall to the bottom upper to
that
now all the long our analyzers are
shining a light through these qubits and
the will we will be able to measure a
change in optical density from that
light that's passing through the the
cube X and then correlate that to a
certain percentage of the protein now
this blood Willebrand factor antigen
actually measures abnormal protein as
well as normal protein so it doesn't
tell us if the protein is functional it
simply tells us that the protein is
present in these individuals moving on
to the activity assay the activity
actives are based on taking normal
platelets either from a donor or for
formalin-fixed platelets adding von
Willebrand factor to those platelets and
then the buckle.very factor will cause
those platelets still good and then we
can look for a change in optical density
and the gold standard method for
assessing von Willebrand factor activity
it's the risk this evening cofactor acts
8 this athlete measures the ability of
fungal growth factor that in the
patient's plasma to induce and a
goodness
reaction in normal platelets these again
they can be normal formula fix platelets
or normal filter platelets but these
will undergo an agglutination reaction
when arista season is then introduced
into the into the new year
so again patients plasma normal donor
plasma wrister season and they would get
a reaction this isn't a an example of
what the admission reaction would look
like a little attacker domitor so we
simply measure the slope of this
aggregation of this agglutination
reaction that has occurred and then we
correlate that to a calibration curve
that we've run prior to running that
patient sample on our platelet aggregate
this will give us a measure of that of
the functional activity of that gun
Willebrand factor again this is a gold
standard now how good is the risk of
taking cofactor well there are some
problems with the resistant cofactor in
terms of its coefficient of variation we
know that these can range anywhere from
10 to 30 percent most that being said it
still is the gold standard when it comes
to measuring von Willebrand factor
activity now a modification somewhat of
this actually in order to determine what
a little brain factor activity there is
a latex particle enhanced in your
computing metric assay and actually uses
a specific but we'll bring the anti-gun
Willebrand factor model clonal antibody
that recognizes the regional de bundle
brad factor where the glycoprotein 1b
receptor platelets would bind to and so
in this up in this assay we have latex
beads that are coated with that specific
antibody when we ask the patient's plan
but to the cuvette
if that reason is available it will bind
to these latex particles and it will get
a gluten ation reaction occurring
whereby will get an increase in light
that's shining through the cuvette and
you can measure that change in the in
the light that's being transmitted
you bet and then this would be read from
a calibration curve additional axes that
mimic the immune of carbon metric assay
there is one where there is no risk of
season that's at it and in this
particular assay there's an antibody
against the glycoprotein one reality
that's captured onto a polystyrene
particle and now this gain of function
mutation then would induce the the
agglutination reaction and so this tries
to do the very same reaction in the
absence of mr. Seaton and and finally
there's another actually out where risk
seeking is added back to the reaction
and it's an immuno committed metric
assay that using recombinant fraction of
the glycoprotein 1b alpha receptor and
then of the mr. Seaton is added to
induce of the binding of this monoclonal
antibody to one Willebrand factor that
leads to the illumination and we can
simply measure the change in optical
density factor 8a say you you all are
very familiar with what would simply
involves taking a patient plasma that
has an unknown level of factory so we
get a fairly prolonged clotting time we
were to to to do an activated partial
thromboplastin time on this sample and
then we take a normal plasma that
completely deficient in factory which
would have an extremely long prolonged
clotting time and then we simply look
for a correction in the clotting time
when we mix these two plasmas together
and then we encourage the number of
seconds they would get to a calibration
curve to determine what the level of
factory was in the patient's flat but
that led to the correction in the
mixture
moving on through multiple analysis
again this is an electric red gas a
whereby a sample is applied to up to an
order of gel we have different types of
argos gels with different concentration
larger offs we have what's called a low
resolution gel with less than one
that are gross that leads to a very good
separation of those larges on a little
break back from ultimate and then we can
have any combination leading up to a
higher resolution gel which would be
very good except separating those
triplet structures that we see once we
apply an electric charge to this to this
to this gel so once the electric charge
is applied it causes advance to migrate
through the gel and then we ultimately
end up with high molecular weight
intermediate molecular weight and low
molecular weight up multimers these are
then fixed using an antibody to put a
little rat factor they are transferred
onto nitro cellulous or nylon or some
other material we then can visualize
these and we can even quantitate the
bands using a distance ometer we'll need
it to one of their axes that's very very
good assay out there that's used in many
parts of the world is the collagen
binding assay and this measure the
ability of the large one will grant
vector mode we're supplying two collagen
so it would be a very good acid to
counter your preciate between type 1 to
a 2 being type 3 von Willebrand's nice
and there's a number of reports that
suggest that it's far more sensitive to
then the von Willebrand factor with
specific and cofactor I say to the loss
of those high molecular weight multimers
and simply it's a it's analyzer
basically what plates are coated with a
collagen and then we simply add a
patient's plasma and and a number of
other things and then we can read we
read the amount of light that's
transmitted in our you're like a plague
reader a few problems with the assay is
that number one it's not really
standardized
throughout number two there are
different sources of collagen so that
can be some variability in results and
their plate the rich decedent induced
platelet aggregation that I mentioned I
can just show you how this really works
it helps us to identify type 2b but a
little brain disease and platelet type 1
Willebrand disease from all of the other
categories of
right disease so in the laboratory when
we do our platelet aggregation we often
use various doses and wrist aceton a
high dose and a little dose the high
dose be in 1.5 mix per mil and a low
dose than 0.5 milligrams per mil so if
you take a normal individual and run one
point five milligrams per mil you will
get a very nice deflection of the curve
on that very same normal individual if
you use 0.5 milligrams per mil you are
expected to get no reaction by the
flightline that was you right here so
this is perfectly normal in those
patients where there is this gain of
function mutation type to be or Sue
Ellen will bring these what you see is
that was a high dose service this
evening 1.5 mix per mil we get a very
nice deflection of the curve and when we
use 0.5 mix per mil and then we also get
a very nice deflection of the curve so
by this increase or this hyperactivity
to the low dose of drift aceton this
would suggest type to be fun will drive
disease or platelet typo and we'll of
rare disease turning to the
pre-analytical variables certainly
phlebotomy conditions are important
patient stress levels if you were to
draw blood from a five-year-old kid and
the arms are flailing around and the
child is screaming and crying this leads
to a an increased amount of stress and
higher levels of and will grant a factor
in these patients certainly if you draw
the blood when they are relaxed and at
ease you'll get a true reflection of the
amount of one Willebrand factor that's
in these patients sample processing and
sample storage you're also
pre-analytical variables a study was
done by Bouldin Co works to show that
the von Willebrand factor antigen there
was this evening cofactor in the factory
if they were drawn in blood and left in
room temperature for three hours these
would be the normal levels
if example were placed on an ice and
then
tested in three hours that would appear
to be a decrease in the level so
certainly you don't want to really place
the sample on ice and we can say see the
same phenomenon if we looked at the
multiverse studies we'll look at the the
one in the middle of the test type 1 but
Willebrand disease we see that in the
baseline sample we have high
intermediate and low molecular weight
multiverse when the sample set at room
temperature for six hours again high
intermediate and low but when the sample
was placed on ice and then tested in six
hours it appears that we've lost the
high molecular weight and a real
reduction in the intermediate molecular
weight and we're just kind of left with
the moment like they're waiting
multimers so these cannot have actually
more but it will break factor levels if
we place them on ice certainly race
plays a role of fun Wilburn factor
levels are higher in African Americans
and Africans and in other racist age
plays a role when Willebrand factor
increases with age and certainly the [ __ ]
blood groups clear mobile this is a
study done by Gill and co-workers which
where they looked at individuals with
type O a B and a B blood types these are
the number of individuals that were
looked at ranges from 109 to 456 with
each one of the types and we can see the
mean of the normal range that they got
from typo being about 75 percent versus
123 for patients with type a B and so as
a result of if you use their particular
range your cutoff would be about thirty
five point six for the low end and 157
for the high end I know that many
laboratories generally use something
around 50 to 150 so one we just want to
consider what type therefore saying
someone actually has type one will
emergencies especially if they have
type-o von Willebrand
I mean they had type O blood this is
just a summary of some of the variables
that can affect but Willebrand factor
testing and what you can see here is
that
it's elevated when it comes to Ainge
chronic inflammation diabetes etc and
it's decreased in hypothyroidism and
type of blood so to conclude von
Willebrand disease is a very
heterogeneous group of clinical
manifestations it requires a battery of
assays but will erect a cure activity
certainly being probably the most
important asset because you want to know
whether the amount of protein you have
is really functional the collagen
binding assay certainly can contribute
and severe imported assay there are a
number of supplemental acids it can also
be added to the armamentarium for
diagnosing blood Willebrand machines in
the laboratory so with that I want to
thank you for your attention and we are
ready for any questions that you might
have thank you doctor sis for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button
well answer as many questions or excuse
me well answer as many of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is is multiply
analysis needed for all types of VWD
diagnosis that's a very good question
multiple analysis is not needed really
for every type of diagnosis and von
Willebrand disease if you're looking at
someone with type 1 when you already ZZZ
the analysis is good is going to come
back normal
it's would only be if you were to try to
determine how much is a protein that's
present that's going on something like
densitometry or actually look at the
bands themselves two seasons they were
somewhat reduced but multiple analysis
is not really needed for all diagnoses
and one Willebrand disease but as you
can see from
what we've looked at it certainly helps
us to differentiate between five to
eight type to be if you suspect that
someone has type 3 bundle of brain
disease and you do multiple analysis
your absolute you got to get nothing in
terms of the multimers however many
people will order multiple analysis just
to complete the picture okay question
number two how is acquired VWD diagnosed
acquired when bull ran disease would be
diagnosed the users very same athletes
that would use but in this scenario we
would certainly look at patient history
if there was no history prior history of
bleeding no ecchymosis no epistaxis no
general bleeding no matter Raja etc and
these happen to appear when an
individual turn let's say 55 or 60 years
old then we could assume that it would
be acquired as opposed to being
hereditary also if there was no very
history which we certainly use that as a
part of the diagnostic the diagnosis of
this acquired von Willebrand disease
what are the different recombinant von
Willebrand factors used for treatment
this I I continue an email that explains
it's more of the recombinant factors
this lecture really was based on just
diagnosing and not really for treating
patients so if you can send me an email
I can let you know what some of those
four common factors are and give you the
sources where you can find those what do
you think is the best bwd screening test
if I were to have only one vwd screening
test that would be one of the activity
assays what's important here is knowing
that whatever amount of protein you have
invented functions properly again you
can have a hundred percent of a protein
abnormal and it doesn't do you any good
so I think one of the activity as they
would be the very best if you only had
one but you really need activity antigen
and Factory at a minimum so we are
almost out of time so we have time for
one more question
can the appt assay be used as a
substitute for the factor 8a say
absolutely not the apt T is subject to a
differences it's a cloud-based asset so
when we have differences in the
Constitution let's say the phospholipids
or the activator substance we can get
various various reactions to different
levels of that Factory
so one reagent might not prolonged above
the upper limit of normal until you get
down to let's say 20% of factory where's
another one might respond or prolong at
30% or 35% so it really cannot be used
as a substitute for the level of factory
I would like to once again thank dr.
Smith for his presentation dr. Smith do
you have any final comments for our
audience today it's really been very
nice talking to talk to all of you I
hope that you were able to learn
something learnt something new because
I'm sure look at your expert and bug
little brain disease testing anyway so I
hope I was they would bring something to
you that you did not know before we
certainly welcome any additional
questions that you have and we'll do our
best to provide answers for all of those
so thank you for your participation
thank you again for joining us today dr.
Larry Smith I would also like to thank
laberd's and advocate Gnostics for
taking today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing for
June of 2018 you will you will
Seve an email from lab roots letting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon bye
bye